this was just like to me such a cool
clever idea I couldn't find like their
revenue I didn't have a chance to check
but you can go on the site and it's like
to call again I've been trying to find
what are these deductions how do they
work do I do I qualify now interesting
market that I saw so my my father-in-law
was like yeah you know with solar I was
like I don't want a building he's like
yeah if you own real estate you know you
can depreciate the real estate you can
do solar I was like I don't own a
building so what do you want me to do
here he's like well you know technically
you could buy the solar for another
building and lease it to them and then
you write off your hole in your capex or
whatever and so what I found was there's
this business so if you ever notice
there's a long way of saying never
notice when you drive by schools that
schools all have solar panels on top now
and so if you see in California
especially you go everyw middle school
high school is just got solar panels all
along the roof and the way this works I
found out was companies like Chevron and
Exxon or whoever they want so they want
tax credits and so what they do is they
go to the school say hey we will buy
solar for your school and they buy solar
panels for the school it becomes a tax
write-off to them the school leases it
from Chevron and so Chevron gets a
monthly payment from the school and the
school gets lower utilities without ever
taking a dollar out of its pocket so I
thought this is very interesting and it
sort of I don't know much about this yet
and so I may I'm gonna dig into this but
it seems like there's a there's a
business to be had for basically pairing
up schools churches other types of
entities that want solar they want a
lower utility bill they don't have the
money to invest to do this whole
infrastructure thing and businesses
which are looking for tax write-offs and
just make it where you push a button the
project happens and you receive your
paperwork that says here's your
deduction and here's your income stream
coming from the lease so I think there's
a business to be built basically pairing
up the two sides of the marketplace a
physical building like a school or
whatever that needs that wants solar it
doesn't to pay any money he doesn't to
do any work and a company that's looking
for tax write-offs that that's willing
to go give that school solar in exchange
for the tax write-off
love it I'm gonna tell you something
even some very similar as well and this
is in the same vein of
half very half-baked 10% baked 1% begged
most highway medians and government
property or public property has grass
and the reason it the reason it has
grass as grass is the cheapest way to
cover land okay but grass is actually
incredibly expensive to upkeep like if
you're in a median you have to mow it
like the way that the math works out
it's something like I forget the exact
there's there's math behind us but and
then plus having to mow it and water it
and do all this stuff it's incredibly
expensive and in LA I have to remember
the numbers but in LA I think that like
20 or 30 percent of all water went to
watering lawns right and so what they
did was they tested this out and they
gave turf to their residents they just
gave it away they go here right bull
here will do it for you yeah and it
reduced water usage a significant amount
and I started thinking about it I'm like
that's kind of interesting what if you
just went to the government and you're
like I'm we're just gonna let's let's
just turf all the all the medians in
America right and I cuz I heard that NPR
they did this whole this whole this
whole thing they're like about how bad
grass is and I was like that's pretty
amazing I gotta look into this and I
have not looked into it so this I sound
like there's a [__] idiot this whole
episode but let me give you one more
okay so here's okay here's the general
theme of these really random ass topics
we're talking about is when you look
around the world and is what I'm now
training my brain to do when you look
around the world and you see some item
or object or patch of grass just think
to yourself how did this get here and
what you realize is there is a business
underneath every single thing like this
is what going back to when we said you
know in offices you got that poster
about like the kind of HR hazards or
whatever like the super stupid labor law
poster you have to in your office I
think it's a huge business that's a heel
is this I was blind to this right I just
saw this poster I didn't ask how it got
there I didn't ask why it had to be
there why every office has this but
whoever asked that question realized
there's an opportunity here and they
started laminating these [__] posters
making fifty million dollars a year
giving you this annual poster that you
have to update in your office so that's
the the test for the for the listener is
start to look at the world and say how
did this get here
who wanted this here what is the
economics of this again oftentimes the
that that's a good great point Shawn a
lot of times when people they don't
think about that stuff and it what if
you dug deep a lot of times you could
realize that there was some bureaucratic
decision that was a [__] horrible
decision right yeah and there could be
opportunity could be a totally so a lot
of times there's like a scrappy
entrepreneur who comes up with something
cool like that side business other times
it's like well why did you guys decide
to like make the screws five inches
instead of six inches it's like because
like the six on the keyboard was worn
out right right alright so here's
another example of these like hidden in
plain sight businesses all right you go
to a you go to a airport you take a
flight you go to baggage claim
okay cool night nine times out of ten
your bags there now the other ten times
out of the out of a hundred or whatever
you know your bag is lost and they
recover it but there still ends up being
this point three percent of luggage
that's never claimed and point three so
it goes to ninety-nine point seven
percent of luggage I believe is gets
claimed and so point three percent of
luggage is just unclaimed baggage so I
saw this business called unclaimed
baggage what they have done is they went
and they partnered with every airline
and they said to we will take the
unclaimed baggage because they have some
protocol like I don't know what it's
like after 21 days if no one claims it
now we're just stuck with this [__] and
somebody was like hey that is not [__]
that's a suitcase and that's some stuff
inside yeah so they were like David seen
the 16 minutes episode on this it was
like I'm not serious
Alabama Birmingham Alabama I believe
your play there based somewhere random
it's the yeah they have a physical store
in where's yeah Alabama Scottsboro
Alabama yeah I know this company well I
love it so you can go to their website
unclaimed baggage calm it's there's
things as the nation's only retailer of
lost luggage that caught my eye anytime
you say only that means I locked up an
exclusive on this [__] I'm so happy
that I can be the only player which
means I'm gonna extract a lot of value
here so what they do is they donate a
bunch of stuff that they get into bags
to charities cool there's a feel-good
component to this
they take orphaned bags and they recycle
them they sell them or they donate them
and those three combined or a business
and so this was just like to me such a
cool clever idea I couldn't find like
their revenue I didn't have a chance to
check but you can go on the site and
it's like to call again unclaimed on
cane bag it's like you'll buy this
there's a Rolling Stones collector's
limited edition leather motorcycle
jacket for five hundred dollars up on up
for auction on this thing what's it
called
uncle unclaimed baggage unclaimed
baggage calm well we could find this out
I I remember sixty minutes but it did a
big like expose on the a while ago and
it was like oh uh they they have like
tens of thousands of square French right
yeah they're huge huge facility there
the other one that's like this which i
think is more popular people know about
this more is the group that takes the
okay you go to a hotel you use you know
two squirts of shampoo out of the mini
bottle and now there's still three
squirts left and then you check out and
they can't they don't want to give that
empty half-empty bottle to the next
guest
so they ditch it and so some guy was
like wool that's a lot of waste of
plastic and shampoo and so someone
started going into hotels and partner
and said I will take all your used
shampoo bottles conditioner bottles body
wash whatever and so they built a huge
business just recycling this I love that
they take it they reuse the goods they
donate certain things to charity and
it's such a good business it's like
doing good while doing well and I think
those are great I love that here's why I
just googled so Doyle Owens is the
founder of Unclaimed Baggage he's he's
dead now he died recently and if you
google I'm he's just like an old
Southern right white looking to I mean
just a normal ass looking dude and a guy
who watches Billy Madison three times a
day well the reason why I like him is
because or I like this is because I
think that people tend to overcomplicate
things and like I'm very passionate
about the mission of reducing waste just
like just
like the idea of don't consume what you
don't have to consume and just don't be
wasteful I was raised Catholic I'm like
this idea of like gluttony and like
waste it just says it's in my blood I
hate it this [__] guy this is like
the definition of just like turn and
[__] into gold of just like right she's
just like it's a super simple it's not
fancy it's an Alabama which you know I'm
from the south so but no disrespect to
the south but like people look down on
that [__] because I think they're in
Silicon Valley but they're special and
he's just that this guy reduced waste
significantly and got very wealthy in
the process right loved it and created
he probably created maybe thousands of
jobs for like low-income people this
guy's the best I love this if you have
if you know about a business like this
I'll call the hidden in plain sight you
know super simple ideas just things that
when you look around the world most
people just take them for granted and
then somebody out there's like no wait
how did this get here who picks this up
when it's done what's the business of
that tweet those at me I want to know
what other businesses are like this out
there
did you joint did you make a life to get
them do you make that term up
no I think they use that term for like
serial killers that are just in society
so like that's where I've heard it it's
like for criminals in some way but I
don't know yeah it's a phrase do Doyle
Owens is this guy's name who started
Unclaimed Baggage I love this guy Doyle
I hope you listen to this he's dead
sorry I said you know dad I'm looking at
a [__] where he's dead damn this guy is
[__] awesome don't no one go into
this market I want this family to be I
love this family three seconds of
silence for Doyle [__] there's a big
newer time this is I got to cover this
on the hustle this is a super
interesting story an example of this
that you guys covered on the hustle is
the mannequin lady in Oakland yeah takes
you know I guess either used or damaged
mannequins out of stores because again
what are you gonna do with this hunk of
plastic like who needs this mannequin
and she's just got a warehouse of
mannequins and then ships them out and
makes it killing so so there that's
another example of these Oh like these
are parts of the world that you didn't
realize are businesses
you
[Music]